on pensait avoir vu toutes les images de
cette tragédie
mais 17 ans plus tard un ancien
cameraman témoins de l'effondrement des
tours jumelles publie une vidéo inédite
replongeant le monde entier au coeur de
cette horreur qui a changé à jamais le
visage des états unis le temps passe la
douleur reste aujourd'hui les américains
se souviennent
à new york on a prononcé le nom des 3000
victimes du 11 septembre 2001 à 9h20
l'effervescence de la bourse de new york
s'est tue le temps d'une minute
le président américain dans notre homme
s'est rendu en pennsylvanie lieu de
l'écrasement du vol 93 de la united
airlines l'un des quatre avions
détournés par des pirates de l'air cette
journée là le seul qui n'a jamais
atteint sa cible
c'est l'intervention des passagers qui a
forcé la chute de l'avion dans un champ
plutôt qu au capitole à washington
ils ont changé le cours de l'histoire a
dit le président salué depuis des années
le héroïsme de ses passagers et des
membres de l'équipage et honorés
aujourd'hui avec l'inauguration de la
tour des voix un monument constitué de
40 carillon pour les quarante voix de
ses héros vous n'êtes pas seuls a lancé
le vice président mike pence
dans son discours au pentagone
s'adressant directement aux familles des
victimes du mépris pour tous les
américains sont avec vous at il ajouté
[Musique]
rare moment d'unité nationale dans ce
pays c'est vrai et c'est jacques houde
rue charbonneau radio canada montréal